So why are we here? I think this talk, we want to kind of accomplish two aims. One is talking about how UFOs are real. They're real phenomena. They're a real thing. But I think that's somewhat passe and conventional at this point. Over 50% of the American population at this point probably believes in the existence of UFOs.
We're at hereticon. So I think the real heresy here would be actually linking UFOs as a modern observable scientific phenomena with past religious phenomena. So angels and demons would be kind of the popular nomenclature of the past. Is what we're experiencing today what we've experienced in the past? And so is religion actually real?
You know, the Latin root of religion is religare, which means to relink. And it's our belief on this panel that through observing.
UFOs, we can relink ourselves with, you know, kind of a past epistemology that we've always had, and that modernity is actually somewhat of an aberration from that epistemology.
So I have two amazing guests to discuss this with me. First, I have Diana Walsh Pasulka. She is a classicist and religious studies professor who specializes in Catholic history.
She wrote a great book in 2014 called Heaven Can Wait about the Catholic concept of
purgatory. And then very interestingly, she followed that up with two books on UFO phenomena as kind of a meta religious modern phenomena.
In 2018, she wrote an amazing book called American Cosmic, which is like the modern ufology Bible. I highly recommend you read it. And in 2023, she wrote a great book called Encounters.
And she in her own right is somewhat of a, you know, kind of a mystic and truth seeker. And so very honored to have her. We also have Colonel Carl Nell on stage.
Very excited to have him. He's a very polymathic thinker. And it's always hard to present him because his CV is very long and impressive. But he worked at aerospace companies like Lockheed Martin, Northrop Grumman.
He's commanded every level of the army to brigade. He helped set up Army Futures Command. So he ran a lot of tech modernization efforts for the army. And probably most relevant for this talk, he was the army representative for the UAP or Unidentified Anomalous Phenomena Task Force.
Anomalous Phenomena Task Force, which basically was directed to look into UAP, UFOs, I'll use
those interchangeably, and their existence and reality. And so he's privy to a lot of classified
information, but here he'll be talking about the non-classified information. I want to start
with you, Carl, to allay audience, how would you convince them that UFOs are real? Because this
whole talk is kind of predicated on that fact. Well, thank you, Jesse. It's a pleasure to be
here and great to be here with Diana and really excited about this event. So yeah, we actually
looked into this area and so probably privy to a lot of information that's not publicly available.
So how can the rest of the folks out there maybe have some confidence that there's some reality
to this subject? So there's sort of three lines of evidence that you can look at. There's the
first principles, there's sort of testimonial from people who have been involved in the
UFOs, and then there's sort of testimonial from people who have been involved in the UFOs. And so
people that are in positions to know, and then there's the data. So like if we're going to kind
of run through those from first principles, the going in position is probably the laws of physics
are the same here that they are everywhere else. And undoubtedly there's some exceptions,
but in general, that's pretty much accepted by everybody. And so if you look at how quickly
life evolved on our planet, the argument that's usually made is that life is uncommon
and that faster than light travel is not possible.
And both of these things really have no evidence for them. It's the exact opposite.
So for instance, there are blue-green algae fossilized in stromatolites from 3.5 billion
years ago. And recent scholarship has indicated that life may have evolved even earlier,
4.1 billion years ago. So the earth itself is 5 billion years old. The crust has not even cooled
by 4.1 billion years ago. So there's evidence that life evolved on earth at the earliest possible
time, even earlier than would be reasonably suspected. There's microbes that can live in
outer space that we've determined are viable. And recently, as of maybe a month ago, people
identified microbes that were in stasis in 2-billion-year-old terrestrial rock that were
brought back to life. So in essence, life is either evolving very quickly or some sort of
panspermia situation is going on. That's what all the evidence sort of suggests.
If you look at the sun, the sun is what's called a Population 1
star. There's 20 billion Population 1 stars in the galaxy. The sun is like a relatively young
Population 1 star. There's stars that are like the sun that are 5 billion years older than the sun.
So that's like a massive amount of time for other civilizations to potentially evolve on these other
planets, and just statistically. So then you look at like faster-than-light travel, like can they
get here? You don't even need that assumption. But Miguel Alcabir, a Mexican postgraduate student,
who's a professor at the University of Mexico, in 1994 solved Einstein's equations for an effective
faster-than-light mechanism. NASA's looked into this. There's no dispute that the solution is a
valid solution, so it requires this thing called negative energy to work. Well, negative energy is
a component of quantum mechanics. The Cosmere effect, which was known in the 60s and demonstrated
in the 90s, is evidence for the existence of negative energy. The expansion of the universe,
which is accelerating, is due to something called dark energy. Dark energy is negative energy. So
we've got an effective solution for Einstein's equations that requires negative energy, and we
know negative energy exists. This isn't an engineering solution, but it is a theoretical
solution. So it's very much disingenuous to suggest that life is uncommon and faster-than-light
travel is possible. Both of those are false. So that's sort of the first principles argument,
once you kind of put that into the context of all the other evidence.
Let's look at testimonial. Now, testimonial isn't hard scientific factual data, but then
you've got to explain why people such as Barack Obama, Donald Trump, all say that UFOs are real.
They're in a position to have been briefed on this. You can look at the Admiral of the Fleet,
Lord Hill Norton of the United Kingdom, former Minister of Defense staff,
has basically said UFOs are real. You can look at Haim Eshed, the father of the Israeli space
program. Haim Eshed, the father of the Israeli space program, has basically said UFOs are real.
You can look at Haim Eshed, the father of the Israeli space program,
Haim Eshed, the father of the Israeli space program,
that says non-human intelligence is real. You can look at Paul Hellyer,
the former Minister of Defense for Canada, who said non-human intelligence is real.
You can look at Chris Mellon, who's the first Assistant Secretary of Defense for Intelligence
for the Undersecretary for Intel and Security, has come out and said UFOs are real.
You can look at David Grush, who just testified last year before the House
Committee on Oversight to the effect that there is a government program looking at
the UFOs because they're real. And he was accompanied by two naval aviators that said
the same thing. You can look at Lou Elizondo, who's a very famous UAP whistleblower.
And there's many more of these. So that's sort of like the testimonial evidence. In fact,
you can look at the legislation that was just submitted by Senator Schumer and Senator Rounds,
and as well as Senator Rubio and Senator Gillibrand and several other of their colleagues last year,
that basically said, we need to look into this, the Congress is not being told the truth.
And there's evidence that the government knows more than what they're saying about this topic.
In fact, Senator Rounds and Senator Schumer had a colloquy to discuss this very topic
and intended to reintroduce that legislation. And so then you can look at the data. We've got
videos, what they call colloquially, the floor, the gimbal, the go fast video,
that show unidentified flying objects that the Pentagon has asserted are not our,
and are not our adversaries, and they date from events that happened in 2004 and 2015.
You can look at the experience of Gordon Cooper, one of America's first Mercury 7 astronauts who
chased UFOs in 1951 over West Germany, and it testified before the United Nations in 1979 to
that fact. You can look at the incursions over the northern U.S. ballistic missile warning system in
the 70s, where radars were picking up UFOs, and then you can look at, in the 1960s, the readiness
status change of our ICBMs at Malmstrom Air Force Base, where missiles were taken offline, and then
in the Soviet Union, an analogous thing, where missiles were brought online, and there are FOIA
documents and testimony to the reality of that. There's an agreement between the former Soviet
Union and the United States that's still in force, intending to reduce the threat of nuclear war,
where there's a stipulation that either side will notify the other if UFOs impact their
missile early warning systems. So people say, well, if this is real, why don't they just land
on the White House lawn? Well, in 1952, the radar visual sightings over Washington, D.C. for two
weekends, including air-to-air intercepts that precipitated the largest press conference since
World War II up to that time. And so people say, well, okay, why don't they just land in the middle
of the day? And that's happened in 1994 in Rua Zimbabwe, where craft landed and beings presented
themselves to elementary school-age children in the middle of the day. That almost similar,
identical incident happened in 1966 in West Hall, Australia. There's a concerted correlation between
UFO or UAP activity in nuclear sites. The PANTEC site in Texas and the Hanford Plutonium Production
Facility have numerous UFO sightings and correlations. And in fact, this extends to
overseas sites. Even the Fukushima incident had correlations. So looking at the evidence,
both from the standpoint of first principles, from the standpoint of people who would know,
and from factual information, it's indisputable that this is a real phenomenon.
And when it comes to UFOs, I think there's this kind of misnomer that this all started
in the 40s. It started with the advent of our nuclear program,
Diana, you've done some amazing work about how this might comport with
things that we've observed in our religious tradition and in history in the past.
Okay, yeah, sure. So first, I want to explain a little bit about what we do in my field,
which is called religious studies. Religious studies is a discipline that is academic. So
I'm not going to, we don't advocate for religion. We're not ministers or theologians. We're academics.
We use archaeology, history, you know, academic.
disciplines in order to look at social effects of basically religion. And most of the people in
the world are religious, more than 80, usually 83, about 83 to 85% of the world affiliate with
some religion. So it's actually important to study religion. I'm not going to advocate for
belief in UFOs. I'm going to tell you my story about how I got into this because I was never,
I never thought about UFOs. In fact, until three years ago, I had not seen close encounters of the
kind and what a great movie that is, by the way. So, so yeah, so I'm not going to advocate for
belief in UFOs. But what I am going to do is tell you about my entrance into this field, which has
ramped up considerably since I started in 2012. So in 2012, I was writing a book called Heaven
Can Wait about what in my field we call ascent narratives. All cultures have their own forms of
this genre of oral tradition or literature.
An ascent narrative is, is basically a person who is either touring the afterlife, like Dante
touring hell, purgatory, and then heaven. A pre-Christian ascent narrative would be the
allegory of the cave in Plato's Republic, where a person thinks that reality are the shadows on
the wall and ascends out of the cave and recognizes that, wow, there's another reality. So this is
what I was doing. I was looking at ascent narratives in the Catholic history and Christian history.
And I utilized archives. So archives are, I've been to the Vatican and looked at their various
archives. They have many, over 53 miles of shelving of old documents. These are the kinds of things
you see in archives, material culture, codexes, you know, things like this. Philadelphia has a
wonderful archive. So I looked at archives and I was looking for data about purgatory, which I found.
But I also found reports of aerial
phenomena by Catholic people from Europe and Canada and United States from 1200 to 1800. And I
thought these were interesting because a lot of times when Catholic, European Catholics say saw
something in the sky, they would have a moment of confusion. What is this? You know, what are the
things they would see in the sky? So they would see discs, light, orbs. Sometimes they would see
things they thought were flying houses. Okay. The flying house of Laredo.
So these, you know, they would see these aerial phenomena and I took notes because I'm a researcher
and that's what I do. I don't leave data out. So I had this long list of these sightings. Sometimes
they would interpret them as souls from purgatory that needed to be prayed away. But they saw these
things. And I thought that was interesting, but UFOs never crossed my mind. So I kept a log of
these sightings. So I showed a friend of mine and said, what do you think of these reports? And
immediately he looked at those. And he said, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't
and said they remind me of a steven spielberg movie they look like ufos and i thought he was
silly okay i thought he was silly um i didn't think about it again until i started to publish
my information about these events and reports what now i call angel contact events generally is what
i uh how i refer to them um i started to get inquiries from people at aerospace companies
and not just one i got a lot and i was thinking that this was strange because this has never
happened to me before when i was writing about catholic history but it was the specific um thing
which was the angel reports and they wanted my data and they were very interested in certain
things they wanted to know what did the people describe seeing um did the people describe uh
light what was the color of the light uh what
did the objects look like and most interesting to me did the people report injuries okay did
the people report injuries well yes actually they did but um so they wanted my data i happened to
meet one of these people uh this was quite an impressive person is i call him pseudonymously
in the book that i wrote about this um tyler and he had amazing credentials he worked for
our space program he was the government liaison to elon musk for certain
missions
and he said that they had acquired debris from ufo crash sites and that he was reverse engineering
these and they were creating this technology kind of game-changing technology that was in 2016 that
i went with um with people that i had to have as pseudonyms okay so now gary nolan has come out and
that's actually a relief to me that he's come out as himself and the reason why we went was because
tyler
who's still a pseudonym for a person who is a mission controller and works in the space force
so whereas i was looking at these as maybe metaphoric or historical you know not necessarily
well not at all real that's not what we do in my field we're not looking at these as real
things all of these very intelligent um credentialed highly placed people scientists
were looking at these as if they were real and so that was shocking to me okay um i then looked back
at my tradition at the catholic tradition and i looked at some of the most iconic um angel contact
events and i began to understand them in a different way and one that you might know about
is the um the stigmata so the stigmata happened to saint francis of assisi arguably the most famous
saint of the catholic church uh you even though you may not be catholic you've seen statues of him
if you've you know gone into gardens you'll see him he has you know usually a bird on his shoulder
or something like that so a very charismatic person living in the 1200s in europe and um
he had an experience of thankfully they have one of these here of this seraphim so if you'll see
over here in the icon of this event is a seraphim which i thought was really it actually convinced
me to come i was like yeah i'll come and i'll talk about what i've studied and you know what
i know about um so the seraphim um is uh is this angel and it doesn't look like the angels that
typically know about and um well if you look at the primary source material of these contact
events it looks like that and it generally has an eye in the middle of it and it doesn't
injure i looked at the primary source material for saint francis of assisi and what i found
was that when he had this contact with this thing that he described as a seraphim it came down
was light. It had an eye. And there are competing primary source reports, but the best report shows
that Brother Leo, who's about 15, he's watching, and he sees that this is how he describes it,
that this thing dealt harshly with Francis. Afterwards, Francis was injured, and the
tradition determines that these injuries are called the wounds of Christ. What happened was
that this was a very hush-hush situation for Francis and Leo. And when they went back to the
convent, he tried as best as he could to make Francis comfortable because he was injured.
And they didn't tell anybody. So it was completely quiet. It was a stigma. It was
literally a stigma. And so he eventually died, most likely from these wounds.
And what's so amazing about that story,
the burns on St. Francis of Assisi's hands really comport one-to-one with what the CIA is now
studying as far as people who've encountered UFOs. So they work with Gary Nolan, who's a
microbiologist, Nobel nominee at Stanford, who actually has a foundation dedicated to this.
And the CIA came knocking at his door, and they're like, we have these files of people who've had
all these anomalous experiences. And they really comport with, it's like he had electromagnetic
radiation.
They just didn't really have the words to describe it. But in using the term stigmata and
stigma, we bring up this idea of non-disclosure, this idea that power structures kind of
institutionally gate reality from us. So is that happening in the modern UFO context as well, Carl?
Yeah, thanks for that question. So yeah, exactly. So there's sort of six principles or reasons for
non-disclosure of this information from a government standpoint, the first being
national security. Like you don't want the adversary to know what you know and so on.
And then the second reason is sort of lack of a plan. This is so profound and impactful. And as
Peter Thiel sort of alluded, there may be technology with unknown ramification. And if you let that out
there, it could have a significantly detrimental effect. So you've got this lack of a plan issue.
You've got this potential for societal disruption, like the ontological shock
that will come from a realization of angels and aliens.
You've got the potential for a covert agreement where people are benefiting from the status quo.
That is non-public. The potential for misdeeds having occurred and the desire to cover up misdeeds
and the potential just organizational intransigence, lack of a priority that you
expect of any type of bureaucracy. And so this isn't like necessarily theoretical, right? You can
look at historical documents. 1953, there's declassified documents. There's a panel called
the Robertson Panel at the CIA that basically said the government decides to debunk this topic, to
misdirect the public.
To actually infiltrate the organizations that existed at the time, the public organizations
that were looking into this. This is absolutely established fact. Nobody disputes this and the
documents are available. People perhaps heard of Project Blue Book, this dozen-year study looking
at UFOs by the US Air Force. Air Force wanted to get out of this job. They commissioned a study
from the University of Colorado. Ed Condon led the studies, a Manhattan Project alum. He wrote the
conclusion of the study. Ed Condon is a Manhattan Project alum. He wrote the conclusion of the
study. Ed Condon is a Manhattan Project alum. He wrote the conclusion of the study. Ed Condon is a
Manhattan Project alum. He wrote the conclusion of the study before the study was complete,
bragged about it. A lot of the scientists on the study defected publicly from the study.
The study got published. The content of the study is at odds with the conclusions,
but the Air Force canceled Project Blue Book anyway. So this really leads to
what I think are sort of four heresies that maybe we'd like to talk about in the context of the
Hereticon. The first being that non-disclosure of uncomfortable aspects of reality is a universal
constant across cultures and across time. And the second piece, as Diana alluded, is that there's a
hierarchy of being with non-human intelligence being included in that. Cosmism, which Diana is
an expert at, is at the root of both the Russian and the US space program. And consciousness is a
component not only of metaphysics, but of physics itself.
I actually want to get into cosmism. So this idea that, I mean, you met somebody deep in the space
program who was a nuts and bolts contributor to our space program. We think of our space program as
Elon Musk is the tip of the spear. All we have is sort of chemical combustion. But you're speaking
to this guy who, in your book you write about, pseudonymously named Tyler, who is engaging in
sort of consciousness protocols. And that's somehow essential to his work. And then you go
back and you do research about the early American and Russian space programs and how, you know,
you're talking about the early American and Russian space programs, and how, you know,
a lot of these people think that they're in touch with angelic, and in certain cases, demonic beings.
Do you want to talk about that?
Yeah, sure. So, so cosmism, what's that? So there are,
when this, when this happened to me in 2012, I started to get my bearings after, you know,
this recognition that people in aerospace in some of these companies were actually doing this work,
and what this meant. I was shocked. I saw my own tradition from a different lens.
And I decided to go back and to look at the space programs, the viable ones, that would be
the American space program, ours, and the Russian space program. And so I started to do the
preliminary, you know, work that a person does when they're looking at this is, you know, what
were their belief systems? The ones that inspired these men in the early 20th century, late 19th
century, early 20th century, what inspired them to create rocket technologies that were successful
and actually got us off the planet? Well, first of all, these are kind of big Clapham Electronics.
So if you go to the Russian cosmos tradition, which is a similar tradition, you know, where
they believe in, you know, like, Konstantin Tchaikovsky believed in NHI, and that he was,
you know, he believed in this, and he wrote books about it.
And he's the father of Russian rocketry.
They're Christian, they have kind of a Christian overlay to this or framework.
And so I saw this as the beginning of the Russian space program.
And I began to do the same work with our space program.
And in fact, I found it was Jack Parsons.
Now of course, if anybody knows about Jack Parsons, the patterns here match in terms
of he believed that he was in contact, Jack Parsons is the father of our space program,
by the way, super interesting guy, work with Aleister Crowley.
So obviously, he's not giving his NHI a Christian veneer.
But I wouldn't say he's calling it demonic, though, like, sorry, that's my interpretation.
Yeah, yeah.
A lot of people say, Oh, he was, you know, demonic, but he didn't view what he was doing
as demonic.
He actually viewed what he was doing as good.
He thought that he was working for the common task of humans of getting us into the space.
So this would be the, the Russian and the American cause.
In fact, I named my book American cosmic, because I was impressed that we hadn't talked
about it.
And I thought that somebody should
modernity is an aberration that we think man is apex consciousness, that that is sort of
a detour when it comes to the epistemology of mankind over, you know, across 1000s of
thousands of years.
And in fact, many religious scholars in the past have gone so far as to classify a lot
of the beings, you know, between us and God.
And so St. Thomas Aquinas had his angel hierarchies, Iamblichus, who's a Syrian Neoplatonist also
had similar angel hierarchies, and they literally have taxonomies and categorizations for these
angels, they describe them, they describe some of the effects of people that observe
them, some, in some cases, it's literally will say like irradiated light, so it sounds
like kind of electromagnetic, you know, damage.
Yeah.
Or whatever.
So, Carl, do we have any kind of modern scientific frameworks for how we should think about NHI
or kind of, you know, them being higher on the kind of consciousness or evolution chain?
Yeah, so the, the scale that's often used is what's called the Kardashev scale, Nikolai
Kardashev, Russian astronomer back in 1964, sort of proposed during the age where optical
astronomy was becoming popular and radio astronomy is coming on, to identify civilizations based
on the scale.
And that's based on the ability of them to access the energy of an entire star.
So you could build this thing called a Dyson sphere around the sun, and so that would blot
out the visible light, but there'd be a big IR signature, and if, you know, astronomers
could detect this, then they'd detect the civilization.
So he called that a type two civilization.
And then by extension, there's a type three civilization that controls, you know, all
the energy output of a galaxy, let's say, and a type one civilization, maybe a little
bit more advanced from our own.
That's basically controlling the whole planet.
So this is the Kardashev scale, you know, Carl Sagan talks about this, Neil deGrasse
Tyson, Michio Kaku.
It's like a popular thing.
I would argue though, that the scales, it's really not very instructive to look at like
UFOs and UAP, because total civilization energy usage is like an unknowable thing based
on observations of potential craft or potential recovered material or biologics or what have
you.
So there's a better model out there that I would recommend, which is the University of
New York.
Which is the universal civilization development model.
And it goes off of like what they have, what they know and who they are.
And so what they have would be more about energy density than the magnitude of energy
usage.
So energy density, like if I've got a certain energy density, I get fire, I got a greater
energy density over longer time, I can smelt metal, ultimately I can do nuclear reactions.
Maybe I can warp space and time, maybe I can even impact the laws of physics.
So that's the physics of energy.
Jacques Vallée has talked about this idea of physics of information.
So how much about the nature of reality does this civilization perhaps know?
How much complexity can they manage?
What's the time constant for their thought process?
How many parallel paths can they contemplate at a single time?
This idea of consciousness comes into play.
So this, you know, almost a physics of information now is this other dimension.
And then the third dimension is the ecological evolutionary dimension.
What is the chemical basis for this life form?
Where are they on the evolutionary path?
Maybe not just a hundred years ahead of us, maybe a million years.
What's it look like for a life form to be a billion years ahead of us?
What's their relationship with their environment?
Is it omnivorous?
Is it derived from omnivorous stock, herbivore stock, etc.?
So all these things create a phase space, perhaps, that would be populated by a range
of beings.
And the distance in this phase space, you know, we might call it the Hamming distance
by analogy with electromagnetic signal processing, might dictate the likelihood of a competition,
symbiotic or competitive relationship based on the likely hierarchies that undoubtedly
exist.
Dr. Justin Marchegiani Diana, we're talking about hierarchy of
being and man not being the apex of consciousness.
And then we're also talking about us, you know, scientists and engineers at the top
of our space program using consciousness protocols.
If any of this stuff is true, I mean, I feel like a lot of people in the audience probably
didn't come and walk into this room believing these things.
Are we in Plato's cave?
Are we in this sort of epistemic cave?
And if we are, how do we get out?
Dr. Dr. Diana Ransom Yes, that's a great question.
So okay, first off, I don't, I don't think I'm going to reference Peter's talk, okay,
because I thought it was really a great segue into some of the things that we were going
to talk about.
Dr. Peter Van de Ven You know, we're told that there's nothing
worse than Armageddon.
But perhaps there is, perhaps we should fear the Antichrist, perhaps we should fear the
one world totalitarian state.
Yeah, more than Armageddon.
Dr. Dr. Diana Ransom And so I would say that the apocalypse is
structural.
So for anyone in my field, we know that the apocalypse is always happening, okay, there's
always an apocalypse.
So the early Christians who were Jewish actually did have their apocalypse.
You know, the, the Romans destroyed their temple in 70.
That was an apocalypse that those very specifically Jewish Christians were, were knowing was going
to happen.
It happened.
But we go on.
Things go on.
Okay, so what is it then?
So the idea that, that there is an out or that, you know, there's, there's a solution
to the apocalypse, Plato suggests that it's, it's in the allegory of the cave.
So he never answers the question, but he gives this allegory.
And what it is, is basically a conversation, he calls it the dialectic.
And he says that what you can do is you can have this conversation.
So there's a sense of community baked in here.
But it's a, it's more than just a conversation.
It's a conversation.
It's a conversation about justice.
It's a conversation about goodness.
So you're saying kind of contemplation of virtue literally allows you to ascend out
of this world in some way, in some sort of metaphysical way.
I'm not sure.
I do believe that's what he's saying.
And he's, he's basically saying that there is a sort of conversation that you can have,
probably not a text message.
Right.
And and that is a, it's a, that's what he presented.
That's what he presents as the out.
And I think if there's a third option, it's going to be that.
So with Plato, Diana is sort of talking about maybe a proto architecture to religion.
And Carl, we've had kind of offline conversations where you've said to me that maybe the esoteric
version of a lot of the world's religions are actually sort of normalizable.
They actually contain a lot of similarities when it comes to kind of encounters with non-human
intelligence.
Do you want to talk about that?
Yeah.
Well, I think that's actually right.
I mean, the, these sort of the Gnostic tradition, the, uh, Sufi tradition, Islam, uh, the Kabbalah
in, uh, Judaism and even, uh, non-dualist Vedanta all talk about this sort of inward
looking initiatic experience where you're, you know, you're transcending this reality
and connecting with a deeper reality.
So there's, there's actually an interesting, um, study that was done.
The oldest, uh, large corpus, like significant corpus of religious texts, like in the world,
anywhere.
I mean, in any culture are the pyramid texts like fifth dynasty, uh, Egypt, something like,
you know, 2,500 BC.
And so the, uh, Egyptological interpretation of the pyramid text is a funerary, but there's
a counter countervailing scholarship that says, well, actually it's like really initiatory
when Egyptology was created, it moved away from mysticism and went totally rationalist.
And so the ancient Greeks and the ancient Romans.
Anybody that actually knew Egyptian civilization firsthand knew that they were very esoteric.
And so in gypsum scholarship has moved away from that and made the Egyptians extremely
rationalist and very much funeral ritual based.
Once you put it, the initiatic experience into the pyramid texts based on something
called the said festival, which is essentially a kingship ritual that's known to exist.
Then the, then the pyramid and the pyramid texts become an initiatic engine that, um,
that.
That, uh, the living might actually embark upon.
And this is interesting because then it creates direct connective tissue between the hermetic
tradition and the Gnostic tradition that came out of late period, Egypt, and then influenced,
um, both classical antiquity and then early Christian, um, theology.
So you've got essentially a linear line that can now be traced potentially to the earliest
tradition in an esoteric sense.
There's a great Meister Eckhart quote, uh, theologians make coral, but mystics all speak
the same language.
So I think it speaks to that sort of pre-darkness and there's actually a story I think of Jewish
Kabbalists meeting with the Dalai Lama and they're like talking about these non-human
intelligences and the colors associated with them.
And they're just kind of laughing about how kind of in agreement they are worldview wise.
I want to stick with you, Carl, because we are in a room full of entrepreneurs and people
in venture capital.
And so they might be thinking, okay, this, all this stuff might be real, but I don't
really see it.
And it's kind of ephemeral and like, what does this have to do with me?
Does any of this investable?
Uh, can we turn this into a company?
Right.
Carl, do you want to?
Well, right.
Well, I might hit that ball right back at you because, uh, Jesse's done a number of
podcasts looking into Taylor towns and Brown and some other very interesting, uh, like
heretical technologies.
So I'd invite people, uh, unsolicited plug to check out some of Jesse's podcasts.
Uh, but I would also submit to you, if you sort of look at the arc of technological development,
we're getting to the point that, uh, Feynman had talked about in the early sixties.
There's room at the bottom, which is by which he meant, like, we're getting at the level
where we can engineer at the molecular level at the nature that NG, that, that nature operates.
And so these disciplines that, uh, originally appeared to be disparate, like information
science, material science, the semiconductor fab, uh, genomics, et cetera, all look pretty
much the same, uh, once you're able to engineer at the molecular level.
So information and materials start to merge.
You can come up with programmable matter, perhaps self-healing structures, self-repairing
structures.
You're, you're starting to move into that von Neumann machine, uh, level.
So I would suggest, you know, looking at that area, then we alluded earlier to this thing
called the Cosmere effect, the Cosmere effect.
You put two parallel plates that are conducting very close together and you would expect classically
nothing would happen.
But what actually ends up happening is was predicted and measured is that there's negative
energy states that are, uh, created.
Uh, created in between the plates.
In other words, there's certain quantum fluctuations that are not supportable between those plates.
And there's a pressure that's created between, uh, from the pressure outside the plates versus
inside and the plates compress.
So basically that's extracting energy out of the vacuum.
Like that's like free energy.
Like that's not disputable.
That's like proven fact.
So unfortunately it's not, uh, reciprocal.
Nobody's figured out how to make a reciprocating machine.
You got it.
You got to figure out how to make the energy out of the plates to get the energy out.
So that is something that's potentially scalable to a battery perhaps, uh, but it'd be a one
shot battery.
If somebody can figure out a way to make that scalable, that would be extremely beneficial.
So, so those are a couple, uh, avenues, but just to sort of recap like the heresies, right?
So non-disclosure is a universal constant, uh, of society.
This idea of hierarchy of being, cosmism, you know, the esoteric aspect of, um, reality
being at the bottom.
This idea of, you know, this is the basis of the space program and consciousness playing
a role in both physics and metaphysics where our technology is getting to the point where
we can perhaps develop a physical basis for consciousness and the developed technologies
out of consciousness, which, oh, by the way, any more advanced civilizations probably already
gotten to should open, uh, I think our eyes collectively that there's sort of group think
going on and opportunities that are right in front of our face are being missed, uh,
because, uh, we're not.
We're not incorporating these other aspects of reality.
So in that sense, agnosticism is not like an optional worldview.
Well, Carl, I'll take that plug to the bank.
I really appreciate it.
Um, I want to wrap up with you, Diana Peter Thiel was on, uh, uh, Joe Rogan a month ago
and he was asked about alien, like half the conversation was about aliens and he cited
your work, which was fascinating.
Uh, and he said that, uh, aliens, uh, are not only probably angels and demons, they
have to be angels and demons.
It's because of the dual use nature of tech and the forcing function nature of tech.
And so the Pazulka literal thing I'd, I'd come to is the aliens.
It's not that they might be demons or angels.
They must be demons or angels if you have faster than light travel.
And both of those seem pretty crazy to me.
And so if you have warp drive technology as a deliver, as a delivery mechanism for a payload,
like a nuclear weapon, that's, you can't defend against that.
Yeah.
I find it really interesting.
You talk about St. Francis of Assisi seeing what was probably a craft or an orb, a seraphim.
And um, the last thing he writes in his diary is the Greek letter tau, which, uh, means
conversion.
Yeah.
And so it was like this forcing function conversion.
And so in the world in which, you know, uh, aliens, which are being, you know, at least
in the form of UFOs seen at record levels now, statistically, or, you know, as far as
data, the data goes.
Um.
Is the veil falling, you know, the, the, the, the word apocalypse and its original Greek
means the unveiling.
Are we seeing these things at a greater preponderance because we're living in the apocalypse and
what does that mean as far as how we should live our own lives?
Yeah.
Do you think we're living in a apocalypse?
I think that there is an unveiling going on and I think this is a great, amazing time.
So yes, I think so.
All right.
Thank you guys.
Yeah.
Thank you, Jesse.
I'm here with Diana Walsh Pasolka.
Uh, we just had an amazing talk with Colonel Carl Nell.
And it's funny in our first conversation, you brought up this concept of emergence and
this idea that you would get, uh, kind of interdisciplinary intersections between experts
in various fields, which the UFO phenomena kind of brings together because you can go
at it with so many angles.
And I thought it was a really great conversation between a guy who in a kind of a nuts and
bolts, you know, very hard headed fashion, look through a bunch of classified material
came out of that experience on the UAP task force.
Saying, I think UFOs are real and trying to drive a lot of this forward through legislature
and other means.
And then a religious studies professor who had no interest in UFOs and was just objectively
kind of looking at religious as a phenomena and not even looking at it as some, you know,
underlying metaphysical truth bumping into the UFO, uh, phenomena.
So what did you think about that talk?
I'm really impressed with his knowledge.
So not only is he excellent at nuts and bolts.
Yeah.
Looking at, you know, the technical aspects of UAP UFOs, but he knows the whole history
of religions back to Egyptology and he's able to, in a sense, do what I do and what Jacques
Vallée did, right.
Which was look at the historical record and find evidence of NHI, um, UAP, you know, whatever
you want to say about it, um, angels as they have been termed.
So yeah, I had a really great time talking with him.
And I think that, that, um, you also added a lot to it because you know, both sides.
Well, do what I can.
I appreciate both of you, uh, gracing us with your presence.
And before our conversation, uh, Peter Thiel, who's kind of, you know, helping host this
event, did a really interesting talk on the antichrist.
So he's been focusing on the antichrist and he's been talking about it as, um, you
know, in history, you know, how has the antichrist been represented?
When we think about the antichrist, um, how best to conceal being the antichrist, well,
that is to talk about it a lot and basically to, you know, push this, this idea that, uh,
there's an apocalypse.
Okay.
And that we are, you know, we need to save, save ourselves and do good.
And of course, everybody's going to agree with that.
And that's a great veneer.
And then he reminds, he reminded the audience that that's of course, how the antichrist,
how the antichrist presents as the one that is, you know, giving the solution.
And so I thought that was really interesting.
What'd you think about that?
I thought so too.
He cites Thessalonians peace and safety being the slogan of the antichrist.
I think you look at a lot of evil that's done in today's world without getting too specific,
depending on which side of the aisle you're on, but it's on, it's on both sides.
And um, I think you have a lot of today's evil is couched in this veneer of kind of
utilitarianism.
I'm going to be an effective altruism world is my sandbox.
I'm going to, you know, uh, rearrange the figures, you know, on, on a global scale and
like make things sort of work out.
And that is sort of a form of evil.
It's also outward looking.
So it's never inward looking like, am I doing bad or am I harming people?
You know?
And you met Rene Girard.
Yeah.
I love his theories.
I'm a Girardian too.
And Girard always says, you know, to even spot a scapegoat, you need a third party witness.
Yeah.
Because nobody thinks that they're doing the scapegoating.
And in fact, we're doing scapegoating all day long.
And the, the history of humanity is the history of human violence and that all of us have
sort of, you know, greedy, greedy impulses.
And there's obviously violence up until, you know, murder and large scale war and stuff,
but we do small violence to one another all the time through mimetic desires and jealousy
and that sort of thing.
And we have to look inward.
Yeah.
That's right.
So, um, his professor.
Yeah.
His professor was Rene Girard.
And I was at Berkeley at the time at the Jesuit School of Theology and, and Peter was at Stanford.
And so while he was taking these classes, I was actually driving to Rene Girard's colloquiums
to listen to him.
And I, so I had been exposed to his theories when I was an undergraduate at the University
of California in Davis and his book, Violence in the Sacred kind of broke through and really
destabilized a lot of different disciplines and a lot of people didn't like it.
Because it was such a giant theory of everything, right?
It was really a theory of everything, like a theory of evil, right?
And he, Rene Girard is a, was a Catholic, right?
And he did attend, I believe it was Latin mass.
And so the Jesuits that I was taking courses from, they didn't want to go themselves because
there was something kind of heretical about Rene Girard because there was no, they, they
said that there wasn't anything really transcendent about Christ for Rene Girard.
That he looked at evil as anthrop, like an anthropology, like, you know, that we were,
you know, we, there was no transcendent or metaphysical evil that he spoke of.
I think what's so heretical about Girard is, and why he was so sort of not accepted
both by religious scholars or by, you know, evolutionary biologists in his time is because
he has this sort of theory of everything, you know, this kind of proto architecture,
like to religion.
And so that's like real heresy.
Yes, it absolutely is.
Right.
And we talked about that earlier in the context of Plato.
Maybe another person who has this kind of proto architecture of religion.
So we were talking, you know, off camera before this, you were saying, you know, you interpret
Plato maybe slightly differently than a lot of kind of quote unquote philosophers or scholars.
That's right.
Yeah.
So of course I read Plato, you know, early on as an undergraduate and again, as a graduate
student, but I really didn't start actually reading Plato until I encountered the people
who believed in UFOs.
And I saw the, the ways in which UFOs have been, you know, concealed by our government
within this environment where I witnessed harassment firsthand, saw people who were
the quote unquote whistleblowers being harassed.
And you know, it's not pretty, it's terrible.
And I was depressed.
So I thought, you know, how do I make sense of this?
And so Plato's Republic kept coming back into my head.
And Plato, by the way, he asked the question.
Can there be a just society?
And why he asks this is because he's pretty horrified by what happened to his mentor.
His mentor was killed by his government, which was Athens and his, and Socrates was given
it out.
But he didn't take it.
Instead.
He said, I live by the laws of Athens and I'll die by them.
And this is just, this is right.
Well, Plato didn't buy that.
It seems he has a dialogue between Socrates and Glaucon and they asked the question, can
we have a just government?
And they go through all these ridiculous scenarios.
He's saying that, no, it doesn't look like we can figure out how to have a just government.
How do we do it?
Well, then he performs it.
He does a performative thing at the end of the Republic.
And so what does he give us?
He gives us two things that we call allegories or metaphors.
One is the allegory of the cave.
People are, you know, see shadows on the wall and they think that this, and people are showing
them these shadows, by the way.
So we tend not to know.
We tend to discount that.
But there are other people that are like, or things that are showing us these shadows
and we are thinking that they're reality.
And somehow we get out and we ascend out of the cave and we recognize that, wow, most
people are completely blinded by this.
Okay.
So how, how does this work then?
And so then he'd like throws in basically the first recorded or one of the first recorded
NDEs, which is the myth of Ur, which is about the soldier who dies in battle and has a near
death experience.
Yeah.
And so he tells this story.
Well, those are two very strange ways to end this book about the just society.
And so when I'd asked my professors, you know, what does this mean?
Cause I went back to them.
And I even asked my friends who are philosophers.
So what do you think about this?
Oh, it's just a metaphor.
It's just an allegory.
Well, I don't think it is.
So there, so what's then the takeaway?
The takeaway is a performative thing.
It's nothing that you can say, Jesse, do this, do that.
It's just an allegory.
Well, I don't think it is.
So there, so what's then the takeaway?
The takeaway is a performative thing.
It's nothing that you can say, Jesse, do this and it'll be all right.
No, you have to actually do it.
What is it?
Well, it's basically creating a community of people like the other person.
So you know, it's called the dialectic and it's a form, it's a mystical conversation
basically, which is really hard for us to wrap our brains around.
What does it even mean to have a mystical conversation?
I think that if people are watching this talk, they've had a mystical conversation, right?
And you have too.
Like think of those times when you met that person who's like your best friend and every
time you saw them, the energy would change, you know, and you'd have such an amazing talk.
That's what he's talking about.
That kind of community, community based on that.
Because wouldn't you die for that person?
You know, wouldn't you do those things?
That our noble before that friendship.
Okay.
So that's the kind of thing that he's giving us.
That's amazing.
Well, yeah.
And I think a lot of Plato readers think of him as fully allegorical and they don't think
there's some metaphysical architecture that he's actually talking about.
Like the myth of error, I think is a great example.
So the cave is another example, but in the case of the myth of error, he's talking about
this myth where you have an amnesis.
Yep.
Where you have the idea that there's this primordial soul self that kind of has knowledge
of all of your incarnations.
And then you cross the river of forgetfulness into, you know, an incarnation where you forget
your former self.
And maybe through kind of a near death experience or a mystery ritual, which by the way, Plato,
we probably now know went through the Eleusinian mystery rituals himself.
That's right.
And so he probably believed this, like to all the people that think it's just an allegory,
you know.
And so he's saying you experience noesis, you regain knowledge of your kind of immortal
soul.
Do you think that literal reading of Plato is an important kind of overlay that is missing
in today's reading?
I think that a lot.
So you know, I went through graduate school and of course, any kind of literalist reading
of any of these texts is abhorred.
So people are going to say, no, you can't read it literally like that.
And I know.
Okay.
So yeah.
And so, you know, Plato, when he put it this way, well, not necessarily literally there's
a cave, you know, but he meant it in a very real sense.
And that's what I'm trying to get at here.
And yes, there's, you know, this goes against the grain of both liberal and conservative
readings of Plato, right?
It's a completely mystical reading here.
It goes beyond even, you know, some people read it as this is the subjectivity of human
subjectivity.
It goes beyond that.
Because it poses something other than the human itself or himself or herself.
So yeah.
So another thing too, is that the early Christians actually utilize this text.
So in, you know, we've found now in the 1940s, we found a lot of libraries of the early Christians
and we got an insight into what, you know, influenced them.
Well, the allegory of the cave in Plato's Republic influenced them.
You know?
And they found something very transcendent and very Jesus-like, right?
In these texts.
So it's a lineage, you see.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Wow.
What's, are there examples of kind of connections between early Christianity and I guess Martin
Luther King, I think, wrote an essay about the pagan continuity hypothesis.
Yeah.
And so, you know, there's this idea that even the last supper might have been kind
of a mystery ritual of sorts.
Elaine Pagel is also part of it.
Yeah.
She also writes about that.
That's right.
Yeah.
So we're learning.
So a lot of people think that Christianity is set and it doesn't change, right?
Well, archaeology is showing us, and material culture is showing us so many things that
we are learning about the early Christians.
And also, I would suggest that the Greek Orthodox Church really does actually know about this
connection between Socrates and the Greeks, you know, the Greek Socratic philosophers
basically, and this lineage that goes directly into Christianity, early Christianity.
It's a Hellenized Judaism, right?
So it's a Judaism that's completely infused with Greek thought.
Like you look at the Apostle Paul, all of the Greek, all of the scriptures of Christianity
are Greek, are written in Greek.
Okay.
So yes, this makes sense.
Wasn't Paul supposedly, according to some scholars, kind of a Kabbalist too?
Like he was in the Merkabah kind of, you know, Ezekiel tradition.
It looks like it.
I mean, you know, I'm not a New Testament scholar.
So I don't want to go out on a limb and say for sure, you know, that was, but yeah, if
you look at his, you know, his conversion, it looks similar to Merkabah, you know.
And I do have friends who are New Testament scholars and they won't come, they don't feel
comfortable coming out and saying these things, but they'll tell me in secret.
They'll say, yeah, yeah.
You know, Jesus too, by the way, and I'm like, really, why don't you write a book about that?
No.
He goes up on a cloud.
That's right.
Yeah.
And I think that's where some of these kind of esoteric religious practices actually comport.
Like if you look at the Hekelot, the palaces of, you know, Jewish Kabbalism or whatever,
you have seven of these palaces.
Well, in Egypt, you had the Arit, you know, the seven, and then, you know, in Rosicrucianism,
you know, he goes up through seven levels and, you know, he has to leave a garment behind
on each level.
At each level, you always encounter kind of, you know, these different beings, you know,
some are good, some are bad.
Yeah.
Some of them, you know, are all testing you.
That's right.
So it's very fascinating.
So we're talking about this tradition, this Merkabah tradition that seemingly talks
about a form of community, if not a government, a form of community, ecclesia, right?
That's the early church Greek term for the community, right?
That's based on these connections with Merkabah, seraphim, what have you.
These kinds of knowledge bearers, messengers of God, right?
And so how does that, how would that look today?
That's a great question.
I don't know.
How would it look today, Diana?
Well, I think that, I think that we're seeing it now.
I think we're seeing the very beginnings of this type of recognition that they're, you
know,
With UFOs.
Yeah.
That's what I think is going on.
And there's, you know, this recognition that we're not alone.
Okay.
And that was the premise for a lot of those schools was that we're not alone, but you
have to get right with these things.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's what, that's the whole idea was they were looking inward.
Yeah.
So they weren't looking outward.
So the whole tradition, like of Paul, he changes his name because, you know, think about his
conversion.
It was, he was Saul and he was living a life of violence of all things, right?
He was very violent.
Now why he was violent, I don't know, but he was persecuting and wanting Christians
to die.
And then he has this Merkabah tradition.
Yeah.
It was a Merkabah situation that he seemingly didn't cultivate, right?
It happened just spontaneously to him.
It seems, you know, at least from his position, he didn't call it into his life and then it
changes him.
He changes his name and then he works for these communities.
He gives his life to the formation of these communities.
So how should one, an average person sort of conceptualize this stuff because, you know,
it seems like if you read like William James, there's kind of an outer ring of religious
people.
They don't truly believe in the metaphysical kind of architecture underneath the religion.
They just kind of show up to church or synagogue or mosque and they kind of pray and they do
the daily rituals.
Maybe it's this Pascal's wager for them where it's this like hyper rational.
If I do this thing, maybe there's an afterlife.
And then you have these mystics that sort of go straight at the truth.
But that seems kind of dangerous from like a, you know, institutional power structure
perspective.
Like often these mystics are misinterpreted or clamped down on.
Yeah.
By human power structures.
And then even in a more primordial sense or whatever, there's the parable of the four
rabbis who all try to go up into the heavens and like, you know, one goes mad to die.
And like, I might be botching this, but like one, one makes it right.
And so it's this like extremely straight and narrow treacherous path.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is.
So like, why should anybody take that path?
No, I totally agree.
I'm in agreement with that.
Yeah.
Uh, but when students do come through my classes, you know, I teach basic.
You know, basic, you know, survey of religions, you know, kind of thing.
And when we were in the Christianity section, I'm in the South, so there are lots of Christians
in my class, you know, they're, they go to church.
And so I say, why do you go to church?
And they don't know.
Right.
And I say, do you, you know, what about this part of the Bible where, you know, it's talking
about this angel or that angel and you know, this and that, and they're like, well, that
doesn't happen anymore.
Right.
And so I think that they're, you know, so I try to get them to.
To interrogate, you know, their own religion.
Like what does it say?
Why are you Christian, you know, or why are you Jewish?
Like why are you doing this?
You know, is it just because this is your, the cultural tradition, your heritage?
Cause it could be.
And that's fair enough.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um, but what I really liked about Carl Nell's talk at the SALT, uh, conference was that
he basically did the same thing and I thought it was really interesting, but he did the
same thing of, well, you know, you're talking, you're talking to religious people.
People who are religious and all of a sudden they're confronted with the reality that what
they think is this metaphysical thing is actually real.
Well, that's going to be a shock for them.
Are you implying that perhaps we as a society may not be ready for disclosure?
I guess I would draw an analogy though, for people, uh, believe in a certain faith tradition,
whatever that faith tradition is and hold to that and subscribe to that in a very serious
and devout way and, and, you know, sort of pose the question, even for folks of that
ilk.
I, myself as one, if you're confronted with the reality of your religious belief system,
like the reality of the metaphysical, uh, an angel, a messenger from God, what have
you, that's going to be a sea state change in your, in your way of dealing with reality,
right?
Even though you already believe it, right?
So it's one thing to believe and it's another to know.
And I think in this context, this, this phenomenon has an analogous, the potential for an analogous
effect.
Both on the individual and on society.
And I was actually shocked that he said it and I was like, wow, uh, that's kind of what
I say to students, but never in this did never so bluntly, like never like, no, this is a
re reality, you know, cause I can't really say that I, you know, maybe it's reality.
Maybe it's not a reality.
Um, but there's whole tradition of it.
Yeah.
Well, it's still like one of these things where believing this stuff, you know, it can
either sort of burn you or save you.
Like.
I mean, angels themselves are kind of misinterpreted as these like true Rubik friendly beings, you
know, in, in, in the modern day.
And in fact, if you look historically at angel interactions that, you know, a lot of what
you write about, uh, these can be extremely violent and they can, you know, deal with
you very harshly and they can set you on a path that might be sort of more morally pure.
They might excavate sort of bad things that leave you and, you know, you become better
or whatever, but it can be extremely painful in the process.
Yes, I think so.
So, so one of the things that was shocking to me when I first started doing this was the
reality that the government was looking into it as real, whereas I was looking into it
as truly historical, metaphorical, not real.
Okay.
Then I recognize that a lot of people felt like it was their duty to contact these things.
Right.
And that, again, that brought me to another level of like, what a bad idea, you know,
because historically, well, here's an example.
So when I first started.
Yeah.
Uh, corresponding with aerospace people, people in aerospace, um, corporations and things
like that, um, they, they wanted the data, like they wanted to know what did European
Catholics see, um, when they saw an angel or a demon or something like that, uh, did,
did they have any effects, like what kind of effects did they have on their bodies and
things like that?
And did they have any, did they report like other types of effects?
Well, yeah, all that data is there.
So, you know, I started to look at it and I met Gary Nolan.
Yeah.
So I met Gary Nolan pretty early on, probably about 2014 and he shared with me his own research.
So he had been recruited just as I was being recruited.
He was also recruited to work with people who were, you know, in the program, I guess
you could call it, or I don't know how really to discuss it.
You know, he was, the government was looking into UAPs and he was a person who could help.
Okay.
So they recruited him and I got to see some of the research that he was doing.
And some of it had to do with the effects that it had on people and they were like radiation
burns and things like that.
So looking through the historical record, I saw that indeed there were cases where people
reported being hurt, you know, in, in this way.
Um, so yeah, so it's not the best idea then to just decide that this is something you're
going to undertake.
And I never proposed that by the way, I always say to learn, learn about it, but don't engage
in doing it.
Like I propose for people if they're interested.
Yeah.
If they actually have their own religious tradition, check it out, go back to it and
look at it again.
So if it's Judaism, go back to it.
There's a rich heritage, Buddhism, same thing.
Go back to it.
There's a rich heritage.
My, my religion, uh, Catholicism go back to it.
There's a rich heritage there.
So I think that's probably the best way to start looking at it.
And it's so fascinating that contemporary aerospace, uh, you know, people are really,
are reaching out to you as well as, you know, people from NASA, uh, it does feel like we're
on the precipice of kind of this new age where a lot of this stuff seems to be coming out
because the conventional history of a lot of these programs and companies are just,
you know, chemical combustion, nuts and bolts, you know, it's all kind of this materialist
reductionist science.
But in fact, I think when you speak to a lot of the people at these, these organizations,
they're extremely open-minded and it's almost like science.
They're like, Oh, I love science.
You know, I love science.
I love the science.
I mean, I, when I was at NASA and I'd like the first time I went to NASA, I'd seen this
little bridge and I'd seen this thing called the Panacea of the Solar System.
And I thought, oh, well, this is, there's this thing called the Panacea of the Solar
System.
And this is exactly why I started doing things.
And the thing that made me kind of feel like I wanted to take this to Mars in the near
future.
Um, and then I was like, I'm going to do it.
You know, there's this thing called the, I don't know, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh,
where like the early nasa missions had you know uh horus and osiris and um it was like i mean
you told me in our last interview right it was like uh greek and latin yeah you know on uh
symbology yeah first century latin first century latin that's right the empire the empire why do
you think they kind of were paying homage to that tradition yeah that's such a great question so
first i don't know yeah okay nobody would ever give me a straight answer yeah but i did ask do
you think there's somebody in charge who was like yeah like i know that the like greeks had it right
and you have to sort of deal with these nhi in order to get to space and like this is the
program or do you think it was some emergent thing that like they were kind of softly in touch maybe
that's an unanswerable question i don't know um i believe that so my own opinion about this is
just my opinion after looking and talking to people that are
you know the people that are doing it actually you know doing okay so um they would tell me that
this was a way to pay a homage to the sponsors they call them the sponsors and i you know would
ask do they read latin you know kind of thing like really and they would say absolutely i think that
it's a large tradition that goes unacknowledged in our history and do you think it's sort of
hermetically passed for sure
absolutely it is yeah but that's fascinating because that's sort of tying today's space
program to like maybe you know hermetically sealed you know uh egyptian you know traditions like like
how far back does this yeah it's amazing i know i mean it's it's definitely it's not a christianized
veneer so if you go to the russian cosmos tradition which is a similar tradition you know where they
believe in you know like uh constantine chikovsky believed in nhi and that he was you know he
believed in this and he wrote books about it and he wrote books about it and he wrote books about it
and he wrote books about it and he's the father of russian rocketry um they're christian they have
kind of a christian overlay to this or framework but you know we have jack parsons definitely not
a christian um but then you do have the same you know you have the impetus that stays there
it's not as weird as jack parsons but it's weird enough it's definitely not christian
it seems to be greco-roman you know with the the recognition that that that there are these
deities right you know and uh does it go back to egypt i don't know i don't know you know i am not
an insider so i don't have an inside track i just can spot the myth that's being called a myth but
it's actually real that they're like create you know there are they are doing this intentionally
well i think that's kind of this myth in disclosure overall because like
both of us are on the outside but we've like poked uh you know we've poked around like we have like a
decent mental map that's probably like better than just the average person who's like not really
you know interested in this stuff right and like my serious inclination now that was not the case
a few years ago is that there's like no one in charge or that like if it is there is something
in charge it's this like loosely distributed weird thing that's like emerging and has like a
a mind of its own and maybe there are some people kind of tapped into deeper layers of reality but
it's certainly not commensurate with some clear clearance system or classification system within
the government yeah that's okay so i i'm fully on board with that theory and you know because
you can't we can't prove it can we yeah but it's just a theory but i'll give you some examples but
we've met enough people who like people on the outside are like that's the deep state architect
of the godfather of the ufo stuff and like we meet them and they're like well they don't know
a lot of stuff that this other person knows and you know there's like a lot of that's right
going on yeah a lot of it so that made me actually think about the oral tradition of it
because i was around enough people to know that they figured out their missions not from asking
people or having someone tell them they had to figure it out on their own yeah and that process
was hard for them and they didn't even know that they got it right until they got an award for it
like two years later yeah so they didn't know and they would also tell me things like well people
they never knew until they got the the uh you know the uh the card or not the card the patch
yeah until they got the patch or whatnot or they you know they figured it out and so i was beginning
to see it as when i i have friends that are uh indigenous and uh they occasionally tell me a
couple of things you know about their world view and the way that their uh like australian
aboriginal culture works right and apparently there's like a very
um succinct and transmissible oral tradition that is really old like you know what thirty thousand
years old or something like that and it has to do with you know nhl and things like that and so i
begin to see our space program like that like wow that's how it works there's an oral tradition
that's transmitted but it's not transmitted through this memo you know so the declassified
memos what do they really mean you know when they're having a meeting like our chapter is the
And there's this type of tradition.
Yeah, well, all the memos seem like they're kind of groping in the dark and they don't really know what these things are.
I'm a big fan of this mid-century inventor, Townsend Brown, who we talked about earlier with Carl Nell.
And he says it's like, you know, fish in the water.
They don't know, you know, they just see the holes in the ships over top, but they have no idea what those ships are transporting or why they're there.
And that really, you know, feels like where we're at.
But you bring up this idea of a patch.
What do you mean by that?
Okay, so the patches.
So in the Space Force or whatever we call it today, you know, where people are on missions to send things up into space, satellites or what have you, they work on these and they get these patches.
Okay, so a lot of people know about these patches.
They have a Roman god on them or something like that.
And they usually have the Latin that describes the mission.
But in a way that's really opaque and even making fun of outsiders, right?
So this is the mission.
You could even, you know, go online and see a lot of those patches.
And I've known someone to have like at least 150 of these patches.
Yeah.
So this is a person whose whole life has been doing this work.
Wow.
Well, I think about the person you pseudonymously named Tyler in your book, and he's this NASA mission controller.
It seems like he's using kind of consciousness protocols to make the launches work.
He's this very interesting figure.
But then he goes to the Vatican with you and he has this conversion experience.
And it's almost as if what he looks into in the Vatican archives confirms that the work that he's been doing is somehow mystical and like way more like globally meaningful than just this nuts and bolts.
Like we're putting satellites in space sort of thing.
Yeah.
That was really an amazing experience for me to witness the conversion that he went through.
We started at the Vatican looking at the records of Joseph of Copertino and a bilocating sister, Maria Vagrida.
And we also had exposure to Peter Gumpel, who had been a papal advisor.
He's a Jesuit.
Talked a lot about the Templars, by the way.
Yeah.
Do you remember what he said about the Templars?
I do.
Um, okay.
Moving on.
So that's where it started.
So he started to re-examine his life, I guess.
Yeah.
And I could see that process because I've seen it before.
And I had a feeling that when we got to Castle Gandolfo at the Vatican Observatory, where he was going to meet astrophysicist monks.
And, you know, those people that live like that, they have, you know, that's their mission.
And their mission is fused.
It fuses religion.
And science.
I knew that that would be his place.
And that he would probably convert at that point.
And I was right.
So then we left the Vatican and we went there.
And then he spent a lot of time in the archives looking at Copernicus and Kepler and, you know, originals, by the way.
And also looking at electromagnetism.
It's amazing.
And things like that.
And I just, like, couldn't get him out of the archives.
Just, like, glued to these.
To these books.
It's incredible.
And the other thing I wanted to follow up on from our first interview is you said this remarkable thing.
And I kind of, like, just, I don't know, I ignored it.
Bad interviewer in my case or something.
Because you said this really profound thing.
You said that when you went with Tyler to the Vatican Observatory, they knew who he was before having gone there.
And that tripped me out when I was watching it over in the edit.
Because I was like, why does the Vatican Observatory, they're obviously very well respected and well staffed.
When it comes to real astronomy.
But how do they know who a NASA mission controller from the U.S. is?
Yeah.
Not only that.
But when we were there, we just happened to correspond with a trip that all these young scientists from ESA, so the European Space Agency, they were all there, too.
And so Brother Guy, who's the director, Guy Consolmagno, he was giving them, you know, a really awesome tour and talk and everything.
So he introduced us.
And so he introduced me.
And they were like, hmm, you know, kind of cool, clap, clap, clap.
And they introduced Tyler with his real name.
And the whole place just erupted into just, yes, like that.
And that was a recognition for me that Americans kind of don't know what's going on.
But they did.
Yeah, they were, to them, he was a hero.
Yeah.
It was really, really cool.
That's incredible.
The other interesting connection with Tyler is.
He met Chris Bledsoe, I think, before you.
That's right.
Yes, he did.
Yeah.
And they had a relationship.
And I think Ryan Bledsoe, who's Chris's son, said that Tyler had told Chris that he was part of a group with Townsend Brown, who I just mentioned.
So Townsend Brown's this, like, fascinating mid-century inventor who I think, you know, made more discoveries in the world of gravity than meet the eye.
You know, might have tied gravity and electromagnetism together.
And that has implications for time as well.
Because if you can shift gravity at all, you can shift time and general relativity.
And he would talk in his private life constantly about time travel.
And so what I found just so fascinating is Tyler tells the Bledsoes that he was involved with a group that was based in Nassau and the Bahamas.
And Townsend Brown was the president of this group and time travel technology was involved.
And I would totally discount that and think that's probably wrong if I didn't know so much about Townsend Brown.
Right.
And with a very interesting kind of cast of characters.
Well, you know, that's so fascinating because when I knew Tyler, he was always talking about time travel.
Really?
And yeah, whenever a new movie about time travel would come out, he would go see it.
Like the Adjustment Bureau or the Philip K.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
So, I mean, wow.
That's amazing.
It seems like we both know.
Yeah.
So, you're kind of like the guy.
the person who talks about Brown, right?
And then he's an invisible where he was until you, right?
And then when I met Tyler, that's what I thought.
I thought more people have to know about this person
because he's an invisible,
but he impacts so much of our history
and we don't even know it.
That's the way, yes.
Yeah.
I felt the same way.
I felt like it was my duty or something
because he died penniless
and I'm convinced his work made it
into the B2 Stealth Bomber.
Like premier, you know, Stealth Bomber,
you know, and he was paid off by this financier
at Northrop Grumman,
like a ridiculously low sum of money
for the rest of his life.
And then not even that.
I mean, I think he literally like
unified the field experimentally.
And so like-
That's so sad.
Everybody knows who, even Tesla got ripped off,
but people know who he is
and he has a great car company named after him today.
Nobody knew who this guy was.
And he created, he was such a patriot.
He was such an American patriot.
You know, it was Cold War era.
And so these discoveries obviously have implications
for, you know, weaponry and all sorts of other things.
And so he created tons of disinfo about his own work
to throw people off the trail.
And so he kind of died penniless
in obscurity on Catalina Island.
And yeah.
So you felt the same duty with Tyler.
I don't know what I felt.
I felt a sense that you have,
like a sense of injustice, kind of, you know,
that we want the world to be transparent.
Let me give you something.
And this can be something that I think is, is relevant.
During the time that I knew Tyler,
there were other people like him, invisibles,
like I called them the invisibles, right?
And one of them had passed away.
And this is a person whose family didn't even know what they did.
So there was a big sense of sadness on their part
because they, they couldn't eulogize him correctly.
They felt because they did not know.
And so Tyler actually asked me if I would help them write the eulogy.
So I did, I wrote the eulogy.
And during the time period of writing it was so emotional
because I was like, wow, you know, how, how do I say this?
You know, so I helped them, I helped them write it.
And, uh, they really, they reached out to me afterwards and they were,
uh, it was consoling to them because they, because someone outside
the family recognized their pain.
That's so amazing.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well, do you think that these invisibles are sort of outing themselves right now?
It seems, it seems like.
Some, yeah, it seems like they're, they're done with this kind of life.
Right.
And they want to, but, um, but again, you know, we talked about the reasons
why I had to go back and look back at Plato's Republic, which was a text
written through trauma, the trauma of a government killing Socrates, the mentor
of Plato, like a teacher who was a wisdom teacher, he wasn't doing anybody any harm.
Um, so in that context, maybe the, the whistleblowers should be, should maintain
secrecy.
I don't know.
I think that, uh, it's not a great outlook to tell you the truth.
I mean, in the long run it is, but there's a, a, a spot that's bad.
It's really bad.
And most of the time is bad, right?
So Christians are told, you know, the world's not for you.
The, this place is not for you.
I mean, really that's what Christianity suggests.
And in a sense, that's what Plato's Republic suggests too, because is everybody
going to do the dialectic with each other and kind of, no, no.
Nobody cares to do it.
But so do you see what I'm saying?
There, there are groups of people who do.
Yeah.
You know, does it have to be for everyone?
No, there's no sort of universal fate and, uh, one needs to sort of save themselves
and, but do that in a sort of maybe communal way as a, I think you have to do it in a
communal way.
You do think you have to do it in a communal way.
I mean, even Buddha said so, right?
He said that there were three keys to Buddhism.
One is that you can do it.
The other one is, um, the Dharma, which is the teaching and the teaching is kundalini.
It could be anything, right?
It doesn't have to be a scripture.
Um, it could be an event that teaches you could be having kids, by the way, you know,
it's a really great way to like, learn about life and yourself.
Um, so there's the Dharma, but of course there's the Sangha and you can only do it
in a group because you have each other to help each other.
Hmm.
That's fascinating.
Well, I think that's the perfect note to end on.
Diana, I really appreciate your time and it's been a great day, kind of a marathon
and, uh, yeah, I'm excited to see what happens.
And.
Yeah.
Both in UFO world, but also in the world at large, cuz we're in very, there's a,
there's a, uh, Confucian proverb, you know, it's like better to live in interesting
times than good times or something.
And that's right.
I guess we definitely live in interesting times.
Yeah.
We can rationalize our world by saying that.
Well, anyway, thanks for talking with me, Jesse.
It's always fun to talk with you.
It was a blast.
Yeah.